well it's time to get into the
valentine's day spirit and love
obviously
is in the air and rocky diaz has got you
covered
this week yeah today she took a trip to
the twilight zone to show us
how we can celebrate with a sci-fi twist
if that's what you're into
yeah if you're into that kind of thing
obviously the kids are loving it this
you can have a perfect play day or
birthday party here but monster mini
golf is not just for the kids
no it's for adults too it's a perfect
date night because we're kicking off
valentine's week so this is the founder
of monster mini golf
let's talk about what people can do here
for date night yeah we're actually
really
let's take a look we're actually a
really cool date night spot um we're 18
holes in mini golf and it can kind of
keep you talking if you're really shy
yeah
if you're really competitive it's even
cool for that look at that yeah
it's very visually stimulating trivia on
the golf course we do contests and
things like that we have music on the
golf course so we keep it lots of fun
that's awesome and i understand you've
had proposals here you've had first
dates yeah yeah we do we have a lot of a
lot of first dates obviously
but we've and we've actually had people
come back from their first date and do
um a proposal here as well
and we've even taken a step further than
that oh my god okay wait before you get
to the step further
i feel like you know in the spirit of
valentine's day it all starts with the
right pickup line right
yeah i guess and in sci-fi world you
gotta have the right
pickup line with the sci-fi theme so
because i'm so smooth i've written a few
downs all right on my paper here
all right so i'm gonna start i'm gonna
start off okay you mind no go ahead go
ahead christina you are out of this
world
would you like to boldly go where no one
has gone before
okay and this one is from my editor
david this one's from my editor david
you're going to like this
you're like a phaser on stunning oh geez
are you flushing under that mask i think
she's blushing under that mask
so after the pickup line after the
sci-fi date night here
we get a sci-fi wedding right we do
sci-fi wedding chapel it's awesome
show us boy show us the way i think we
might have something cool going on
something cool like an actual wedding we
do gosh we have to be quiet obviously
so as a bride coming in here what do i
get
you get pretty much whatever you
integratively
we will do anything it's just a fun
really cool
sci-fi wedding chapel so sci-fi um
vip passes we've got custom takes any
minister you could possibly want
wow yeah that's awesome and of course
you guys have some other
venues around town as well right that
have different themes we do we have a
kiss venue over at the rio and so we
have a rock and roll chapel there as
well i love that
yes it's full on rock and roll so we
kind of got both sides of the spectrum
going on
you've got it covered for anybody never
did for everyone you never did
monster mini golf so last question here
um what makes the perfect
vegas wedding uh imagination and love
that's great thank you christina oh
thank you for this fine establishment
i will should we do the should we do oh
okay
i'm not very good at this greetings
salutations